belle a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti simi
in questo nuovo e business primo
episodio di residenti vol
8 chiamato ha chiamato cerchiamo la si
chiama così presidenti col ville sarà il
primo di tanti episodi sarà il primo di
tanti in incubi che vi verranno la notte
perché ho 26 anni ma mica è roba addosso
uguale detto il villaggio delle ombre ok
l'inter fa una ragazzina e la sua mamma
andarono a raccogliere bacchi per il
padre che lavorava
ok tuttavia la forestale accolse con un
silenzio fritto non regga sembravano in
azione colari di doni della morte di ha
rivolto con guasti sfuggire al controllo
della madre e spari inghiottita dagli
alberi apparve allora il gran pp straw
la saluto con cal grave e mezzo vieni
bambina placa la tua sei anche rocco e
combo con gli altri gusti cover e
l'aveva capito è solo un
misunderstanding si alzò tra le bestie
terrorizzando a morte e la fanciulla
all'improvviso appare di una strega
teneva rosa e ricavi
e quindi il più bello ma aveva mai
ricevuto dei doni mai voluto di più ora
ci è dovuto in un lampo venne
imprigionata in uno specchio proverà la
cavità anch'io ci siamo trasferiti per
proteggerla dal passato ricordi
ricordo benissimo sì ma stai gamma c
calmiamo grazie non è comunque per chi
non avesse giocato il primo hit anche
che questo ma non so non sta parlando
sul protagonista
allora per salvare lei ho fatto un po di
nel sette lo privano di serie tv sono
successe un po di cose ma vabè facciamo
qualcosa di veramente horror cambiamo il
pannolino si può fare questo
no aspetta che cosa è un tappeto che
comunque ragazzi mettere un tappeto a
cavallo delle scale per corte non sono
un designer ma per cortesia
c'è veramente che nella sua casa no
ragazzi la grafica incredibile vabbè era
scontato come commento ma è veramente
assurdo però dal tesoro mio non
preoccuparti sarò alcamese no ragazzi
questo lo dico gli horror dove un certo
punto si sente che nel nel microfono
parla qualcuno damon jato e poi vai su e
annuncia che la bambina che buona tore
che cosa ottieni giù le mani ma che con
le mani alzate schifo ma toccata la mano
e con la rimessa dentro mamma mia
ti sta integrando bene vero anche il
vino è di qui ci sono astemio grazie
però notare i musoni tutta la sera non
credo che te lo darò devi smetterla di
preoccuparti che ritrovarti in louisiana
la gravidanza
chris che ci manda qui l'addestramento
militare e successo tutto in fretta
almeno ora siamo insieme beh tu io rosa
vedrai che adesso andrà davvero ti
sembra facile dimenticare quello che è
successo in louisiana è passato tanto
tempo ormai non riesco a capire perché
tu sia così mira cazzo è successo
ma poi non gliene frega
qualcosa ma poi noi e non ha pregato
niente cene arrivato prezzi e se
guardate in giro come dire ma cosa che
mi appunto ma scusa cosa è successo ma
chi vi sembra il modo di bussare teste
vicana vabbè c'è un tizio mi scusi
niente ho avuto la moglie per l'intro
del gioco ma che cazzo chris redfield e
mi spiace un cazzo perché lei era ancora
viva da come se no no ma dai ma come
chris ci ha traditi ma cosa ci ha
traditi che ne so realtà dipende adesso
ci dirà sì ma stai caro tutti incazzati
si è visto gioco e la bambina libertà
musotto che cazzo vuoi fare con mia
figlia a segno al sicuro sono state lo
vedo togli la per caso eaton notte
raga ma che matarrese così c'è mamma mia
mi immaginavo una roba un po più slim
invece mi ha portato via la figlia hanno
ammazzata a moglie è finito il gioco ci
ha svegliato ma ha portato via mia
figlia man tirato una testata
mi sono svegliato adesso va bene squilla
il telefono in questo momento proprio
vorrei rispondere
e vabbè un cadavere davanti
prendo il suo telefono che non è neanche
mio forester non solo è morto di
rispondenti aterno mi sa che è morto
quello dove erano ristretti cruz
figurati si parte con residenti volendo
è morto uno criminale bersaglio
recuperare il corpo portare via rosemary
e itau winters trasportare del winters
al sito ci per effettuare ulteriori
indagini dunque mia figlia avrà qualcosa
tipo un impeto un virus qualcosa sicuro
per quello che l'ha portata via
non capisco perché abbiano dovuto
uccidere mia moglie è perché mi abbiano
dovuto fare questo ma mia figlia deve
che questo casino non moriano da
valanghe proprio adesso che sta per
iniziare il bello moriamo nella maniera
più giusta e corretta il residenti vol
tipo come è morto questo quadro non so
chi sia ma c'è un pezzo di polizia un
piccione call mi sento voci e robe che
non mi piace stati tutti i cambi per
cortesia a sono piccioni però è la
fratello mio
qualcuno ha appeso dei fiumi sembra poi
c'è scritto ad un utente che noi
entravamo degli stadi piccioni morti a
basie duke e ha già avute grazie no
veramente gr grazie stavo dicendo lui
che ha già avuto esperienza nel
residenti vol prima non gli viene un
attimo da dire ma magari non c'entriamo
in questo posto di merda non gli è
venuto proprio da continuano a cadere
cose era un cane quello tuffi vieni qua
è bello fu dove sono andato peccato
perché pesci morti tutto morto peccato
perché era l'unica l'unico essere
vivente ivy stata una soddisfazione
andato via pupino che è andato il camino
qua non c'è già un schermano ma le posso
entrare qua
meno male che tutto allegro pensa se
invece fosse tutto brutto che il che
brutta esperienza
c'è qualcuno al piano di sopra secondo
me ma devo finire di controllare qua
ormai chiusi aic ha capito che sto dice
hai già capito che andando a inter
gaulle arti così tela pisolo intercooler
però vabbè fa niente non c'è nessun
altro posto se non questo armadio che
entriamo a narnia
c'è un topo a meno male meno ma era la
notizia più bella di oggi tra l'altro
ok non ce ne sono subito porca [ __ ] lo
sapevo ero convinto che girandomi e deve
uscire di qua sta crollando a casa
bianconera boss ne vado
c'è qualcuno che ha spaccato tutto si è
scassato due motori con non c'e piu ma
chi è che fa manco fosse casa tua
ma che ne ha fatto sto casino il cane di
prima soprattutto di scena era enorme
rosa è scoppiato tu ti fai un taglio e
gli squarci tutto non so come fai
impossibile
ora il sangue che c'è per te riceva per
terra
mi scusi le sembra il modo di riordinare
casa meno male che non è mia
cazzo ne so io basta che ti alzi ok per
ora tutto tranquillo era che ho visto di
peggio o meno vedo fuori e mattina
scavalcava iorio cuore voglio
rincontrare il canino almeno in qualche
modo avrò compagnia pero a meno che non
succeda qualcosa di strano tipo
incontrare zombie ma diciamo ma che
cazzo ne so se ho capito cos'è cos'è
e vabbè il corpo è un po il castello
della disney solo che secondo meno nel
castello della diesel possiamo trovare
qualcosa che continuano così tutto il
giorno tranne teste di capra attaccate
al l'albero per questo è il modo di
hanno fatto e fanno la doni natalizi e
capita in questa zona si fa così
l'albero di natale conosco me l'avevano
spiegato parti non ci vado mai c'è una
luce accesa la luce accesa chiuso il
proprietario è sparito a farci ragazzi
grazie
e non ci vivrebbe manco un cadavere qua
c'è cosa che a chi ci deve stare il
proprietario che si vedevano puliva da
un po a me servono dai tronchesi per
spezzare il lucchetto semele dai c'è un
coltello che non è male che non è male
potrebbe poi potreste band inizia
soluzione medica o non mi dicono come
funziona inventario e normale che io
abbia tutto il suo spazio permesso per
messico ma [ __ ] di agazzano
notando che sai che ti manca non lo so
ma ti sembra il modo di cucinare negli
occhi di romei che succede
ma che cazzo fai sei sparato un colpo di
doppietta
e tua moglie non lo so chiede parenti
ancora peggio se hai sparato un colpo di
doppietta e difficile che non si sentano
questo finisce male in 3 2 1 c'è là
fuori qualcuno se lo trascina via bezzi
sparato io ha detto e io mi muoverei
tali questo momento zero non solo tema e
rapina le palle amor di dio tantissimo
tra l'altro c'è anche il seminterrato
questo qua ecco a ecco dove soli parenti
come se ti potessi stupire ancora con
qualcosa dopo residenti vo al 70 ormai
dovete essere abituatissimo c'è qualcosa
che si muove i ragazzi lo vedete c'è
qualcosa che si muove raga
qualcosa si sta muovendo
doni
cerchiamo è questo che è male ma si era
solo un dito che te ne frega
anzi due vabbé fa niente hai perso due
dita e tu dica che cazzo erano vabbè hai
perso due dita
io non son centralismo scappare che dice
[Applauso]
secondo veroli faccio niente però fa
niente e mori è morto
va bene ci sono molti 15 corpi per fuori
stupirla quindi ed è che me ne avesse
dati altri sarebbe stato meglio ma fa
niente va bene così proprio ora allegri
non sto gioco sono contento la pianta
verde e con una bellissima pianta verde
mi curo e miri crescono le dita voi non
lo sapete ma funziona così l'ho studiato
scienze ma posso tornare dentro giusto
per dare un occhiata game sono stato lì
ha fatto rumore si bene eccole qua le
vittime fronte ci sono solo queste il
residenti vol guarda gli oggetti chiave
dall'inventario agli oggetti chiave
adesso sono nello scompartimento oggetti
chiave prova è tutto molto più
facilitato ok io andrei via di qui
tenevano la quattroporte evo che fa il
pieno va bè ragazzi sono sì vabbè o
volessero morto sono mie prime perché
non mi sono stata un in bocca tipo tutti
subito
vabbè torno da man non ho veramente
capito vado lì perché a sto punto va ad
andare come è meglio che andare
dall'altra parte che almeno voi vi siete
levati cioè non ho capito perché avete
smesso di attaccarmi perché avete visto
che ha ammazzato l'alto vi siete cagati
sotto davvero
mentre il 3 non solo questo mi ha
portato stato per la quarta volta la
volta santo iddio s'è chiusa e chiuso
atteso a porta ha storto il suo ha
portato rifuggire cucina cucina
sopravvivi all'attacco ma cosa cosa dove
sopravvive solo 2 milioni di cancro p o
qualsiasi cosa siano
sono pieni di farina colpisce i sacchi
per cercare i nemici si posso scendere
mi sto facendo di questo meglio trovava
sono scesi sotto sopravvivere attacco un
cazzo scardi arrugginiti porca vacca è
pieno di gente ragazze ce ne sono un
attimo ruoli di persone qua
secondo me non vivo più di un minuto e
mezzo maraga non saprò mai sono morto
c'è troppa gente troppo a chi cazzo sono
sbarcato ma il momento veloce grotte sta
morendo sono tutti quadrati
che gioco da ordigni leggerete nel
bellissimo ma origine senso che mi
piovana vai ok sopravvivere attacchi non
posso scappando ma non fa niente male
questo non manca e non finiscono mai
come i rotoloni regina perché sono un po
posso stare qua nessuno mi arriva da
dietro mi sa che questi saltano e non so
ecco infatti con ritmi dove cazzo vado
agli anni hai preso possono dove tutti i
giorni per non machete nell'intestino
non sono morto non so perché si si
mettiti il borotalco fumetti dylan china
si buongiorno non tanto guarda non è che
si abbia speranze pd di prima ok sto
facendo il giro in toto da mourinho
fresco ma fa niente
sono bloccato la strada da sola sono un
pirla mi sa che devo fare un altro giro
mordimi tour e la faccia tanto cento
quindi chi se ne frega posso andare di
qua senza perché misfatti quel martello
in faccia non solo questo annuncio è
qualcosa che è chiusa bene perfetto ecco
la mia vita eppure eppure eppure c'è una
cavalla freccia pure la freccia c'è male
è arrivato il c'era anche prima gigante
le cose bene se sono qua per te
ammazzami a parte a rifarmi faccia
provare qualcos'altro
questo chi è che ha visto the spider man
ragazzi nuovo aveva cioè se qua siamo
oltre le mie capacità di combattimento
cioè nel senso residenti non è mai stato
di zombie se così possiamo chiamarli non
sono mai stati così gianni cavalli qua
ce qualkosa bella freccia tienila come
ricordo hai una freccia in più ma a due
dita in meno questa porta qua è chiusa
successo simbolo qua probabilmente
servirà per dopo posso chiedere viscusi
senza che mi stenti di sgozzare
nell'amore trendy e maria soprattutto
nella morte visto che dove potrei non
puoi stare qui è pericoloso non voto
invece stai pure qualche tu sei proprio
in grado di vivere qua mi hai sentito il
padre della bambina proprio io aspetto
marley di rosa lei sa come picasso
civile che nave pericolo era sicuramente
non era poster miranda l'ha portata al
villaggio è calata allo script madre
miranda di quei mostri
quello è il villaggio che il castello
non c'è il pericolo posso nascondermi
dove ti nascondi tutto
dov'è il rosa chi andava 3000 la campana
c'è avvertita e mi chiude dentro guarda
grazie grazie
c'è gente davanti al cose simili
commercio magari non mi sento non c'è
magari c'è uno spaventapasseri almeno
non si cagano addosso manco loro quindi
non serve a niente ma credo che a
spaventare i passi non fa il passeri non
siano di spaventapasseri ma questi qui
secondo me se n'è accorto a calcare le
altre dita bravo che mister non mi
servono
vai vai vai dentro ponendo però certo
che sì sì no voleva lasciarla pro giusta
aperta perché c'erano persone cosa ci
fai qui che non entreranno chissenefrega
sono tutti a casa delusi ma lei non
risponde il cancello ha chiuso hai
trovato a whatsapp questo il cancello ma
bastava scavalcare ragazzi già facevate
anche voi tubo dai ok andiamo via libera
lo vedo bene lui però si deve sa comoda
luisa capri sono io ed ecco a simila
proprio di testa gridare attirerai quei
mostri stai calmo lui che è un amico sta
indietro
padre santo cielo julian facci entrato
il sangue li attirerà è pericoloso ma
mio padre morì l'acqua ma sono tutti
così cortesi ma se succede
questa gente vuole fare entrare un
moribondo in casa quelli che chiami
questa gente sono nostri amici tra la
testa di culo chitarra dato il fucile
non sei di questo villaggio
no sono ethan julian renditi utile
controlli e dintorni
ho detto vai poveri non so ragazzi si
mai a controllare vai a farli fuori to
peer la chiamano ethan perché ho perso
due dita
vado a parlare agli altri vai a parlare
con chi tifare tanto c'è julian che là
fuori tiene fuori i cattivi ce l'abbiano
fatta ad arrivare fin qua è già un gran
traguardo ragazzi niente male dai
ragazzi questo era il primo episodio di
residenti vo albion ed spero vi sia
piaciuto e molto molto carino usciranno
episodi molto in fretta residenti vol
perché ovviamente non vedo l'ora di
farmi vedere come continua ma fatemi
sapere nei commenti che cosa ne pensate
vari consigli ovviamente niente ragazzi
se vi è piaciuto a sono un bel haj
iscrivetevi al canale per seguire tutta
la serie a è come sempre ci vediamo a un
proseguito bella ragazzi
[Musica]